before the quarantine women had the me
too movement doing amazing work
quarantine
hits
silence it's almost like you enjoyed
being in the house cooking and cleaning
all
[Applause]
day all we need to do is give you a
banana bread recipe and all your [__]
problems went
[Music]
away you know where you g at me dude in
the getch
ladies low key Biden is more
entertaining than
Trump the guy is [__]
unbelievable but they don't let him out
the basement that's the thing you think
he lives in a White House how'd he get
lost in the lawn did you see that
remember when they let him out the
basement they took the leash off and he
walked into a bush in his own house he
walked walk straight into a bush
disappeared like a Homer Simpson meme
just just completely disappeared you do
that in your home there's no [__] way
you do that in your home bro he fell up
the stairs you don't remember
that 375 years old hit some stairs roll
to the [__] top of them Define
physics that's how bad he wants to go to
heaven he's like is this the stairway
anyway I can get to heaven get me the
[__] out of here there was a month where
every child within 2 feet of him he bear
hug and sniff their head you don't
remember
that one whole month every single kid
[Music]
just they started giving him Jewish kids
so there be a little protection he was
yanking off
yamus and just sniffing dandruff off
their skulls bro even his son Hunter was
like you sure that's dandruff the whole
family the whole family is
interesting what' you say knowledge our
emotions acknowledge your emotions n n
no
n we be doing [__] all [__]
day how many emotions you go through a
day I got to acknowledge every single
one of that
[__] every emotion yo how many
emotions the fact that you even got 10
what's 10 how you have 10 emotions
there's only two emotions happy
sad where are 10 what are the 10
emotions happy
sad let me go up to one of my boys back
I'm feeling a little bit anxious these
days what' you say
bro sorry what what' you say I'm feeling
anxious these days I'm sorry bro Todd's
saying he's gay again what's going on
with this Todd gay
again I felt shy in the social
Gatherings well figure it out do some
cocaine you [__] what the
[__] [__] all this acknowledging of
emotions stop all this [__] ladies stop
name in the emotions you get happy you
get sad I don't want to hear about none
of the [__] in between what about horny
horny yeah that's
sad you're not sad yet but I'll
disappoint
[Applause]
you hey at least one of us is Happy is
your birthday today dude happy birthday
man wish him happy
birthday 50 years
old 50 years old you look amazing for 50
years old bro are you full white cuz
this is incredible aging if you're white
if you got some Latin or something in
you it doesn't count what are
you half Italian half Spanish like from
Spain they're
white this is some good aging black
people white people don't age like this
right these black people right here 73
and 74 years old this is
listen those black people behind them
they're Grand Grand parents so you don't
even you don't even know how old black
people are ever but that for a white
that's pretty good aging is it not
objective
opinion and this is your wife how long
you guys been
married 28 years holy [__]
man kids how many two you got twins wow
boys or girls boys oh that's what's up
God n that's just it's so much better to
have boys because with girls there's
like you know guys have those weird
fantasies about like being with them
both and [__] and
like like if you're how old are your how
old are your sons 21 so if they like
shared a girl you wouldn't be like oh
it's gross you'd be like [__] let's
go
like right like they're twins you let
them share clothes baseball mths like
what's the next best thing right
like shared everything their whole life
they're not going to share a little you
know G like
they're identical twins or not identical
twins that's a glitch that's not
supposed to
happen that means one of his sperm
splits into two you Beast bro you
[__]
beast
bro you know how proud that made him as
an Italian bro it was too much in one of
you bro is his come thick does it
like does it come out like yogurt
just you got to like push it the base
like
toothpaste you should have known this
was going to happen he got thick
[__] I got thick [__] this guy [__] K
of sardines falling out of his [__]
every time he has sex it is amazing to
be here at Paris men's fashion week or
as Alexander Wang calls it the buffet I
think he likes to grab dicks guys you
know Colm is a good friend of mine
colm's actually uncircumcised his
parents are here mom is this true or no
okay you don't have to put the light on
her okay she's going to sneak into
colm's dick to hide
just crazy story I didn't believe col
and this week he's talking about it
Non-Stop and I go prove it prove to me
that you're uncircumcised right and he
literally Tak takes out his dick and
then out of
nowhere Alexander Wang just grabs onto
it was [__] drop it drop it Alexander
drop the
dick I asked the I asked C to dress me
cool he's like what do you want the look
to be I
jokingly jokingly I say yeah dress me
like a teacher that [__] the students
[Applause]
right
now that is wrong okay in America that
makes you a pedophile okay I know in
France that makes you the president's
wife but we're not going to talk
[Applause]
about Bridget
MCL she was grabbing dicks like
Alexander
man what type of Middle Eastern dog
Palestinian oh
[__] does that exist no I'm joking
I heard a Jew laugh really loud over
there you heard that one
[Music]
laugh a few moments later what type of
Asian are
you what did you just say your last
name you're from pong is that near
ping oh Mong Mong
huh
Mong from what country if you say Mong
I'm going to flip out what have a
country bro he a say [__] the whole time
hey neither do we bro it's okay you'll
get there one
Dayo we're supposed to abstain did you
guys abstain from sex you did for how
long you still virgins let's
go you're a virgin he's not sweetheart
you've been cheated
[Applause]
on oh before oh thank God I don't mean
to snitch on you bro but that was
crazy so you had sex already you haven't
yo this guy commends this guy right here
Round of Applause for this
guy Round of Applause because n you
don't know how good dick
is he knows how good [__] is you don't
know what you're missing you're like a
Chinese person with
freedom is there a dessert you
like what's your favorite
dessert Publix cake Mar Publix marble
cake sweetheart you are one sheltered
beautiful little
lady what a beautiful sweet girl right
here Public's marble cake is your
favorite dessert come on Atlanta ain't
there something that gives you a heart
attack that you can take this girl to go
get she don't want nothing that starts
with a
d okay so imagine you had Publix marble
cake which sounds like a
punishment but I'mma go with you but
then butter cream icing on top at
whatever temperature you
wanted you just had a meal of it you've
been having that for your whole life
right and then all of the sudden you
can't have it anymore bummer right now
imagine every night you went to sleep
next to
it not only did you go to sleep next to
it sometimes it would rub up against
[Applause]
you
right and sometimes you're dreaming
you're like oh my God I wish I had some
buttercream cake I wish I had that
Publix's buttercream cake and all of a
sudden boom some hard buttercream
cake is just getting pushed up against
you right and then you just got to say
no no no and then instead of eating the
buttercream cake someone just mashes the
buttercream
cake by
itself until it's only cream left
[Applause]
I'm just saying this is what this man's
going that's how much he loves you he
loves you that much cuz he knows what
it's like vagina's amazing even though
that [__] looks
weird you think penises look weird but
there's so many penis-like things like
you have this like bananas are
penis-like eggplants are penis like
there's so many penis looking things
there's not a lot of vagina looking
things you know so like you see [__]
for the first time and you're just like
wao
like that's
crazy what what circles sweetheart do
you even know what a [__] looks
like this girl just says circles look
like vaginas circles bro have you ever
looked at like the Olympic logo and be
like damn that's five [__] all stuck
together like [__]
circles take this girl out the house
more she's the best Circle [__] ain't
even
circular right it's more of like a oval
kind of yeah he knows you don't
know you know what the top of the [__]
look like but you don't know what it
actually
is so you saving yourself from Marriage
you're not saving yourself in marriage
you just being an [__]
[Applause]
so when do we think it might
happen honest opinion I and I don't want
you to feel pressured at all I mean that
100%
sincerely it could happen any time now
you must be pretty
cool if he's down to just kicking with
you for a year without any sex that's
pretty cool but here's the thing I'm
worried
about before we get too
excited his dick game could be TR
[Applause]
he get a real public stick game
right and then you wasted a whole year
you know he's going to come fast the
first month at least you got to let him
get over that don't you saying no but
let's be honest bro no you're not you
think you got this you're going to crank
it before
you got to sit in the batter's box take
some swings first
bro right you don't go in there without
clearing the
chamber you waiting a whole year you're
not going to click click boom before you
go in there if I waited the ear I'm
going to disappoint you
severely the second I put it in I'm
going be like
[Applause]
sorry y you going to hear the best
apology you ever heard in your
life nobody apologizes better than dudes
when we come fast yo cuz we try to fold
it into a compliment we'll be like oh my
God I'm sorry your [__] so fire I
couldn't oh my
God it's your fault it ain't even our
fault it's your fault right if you look
back to like early Civil Rights Movement
the protest of they got better each time
like you look at Martin Luther King's
first protest the march from Selma to
Montgomery that was 40 miles
walking under the Alabama
Sun threepiece
[Music]
suit church
shoes he got to Montgomery he was like
[__]
this where was the next protest in a
diner sitting down okay
air conditioning pancakes orange
juice hey Rosa get on the bus sit down
ride into equality we not doing this
walking [__] no more [__] we walking for
now if you know black history you know
that those events are chronologically
out of order but I'll never let that get
in the way of a good
joke all I'm trying to say is we're
going to get better we're the beginning
of our protest so right now white people
we're so knee-jerk right we don't think
about it we just [__] do the
government's [__] us storm the C
black people y'all get it the police are
[__] us Louis Baton you
understand how to get a two for one
right black lives matter but so does
Christmas bro I need these presents so
we're there but you know multiple people
have shitty haircuts man it is what it
is listen it is what it is you know what
I mean you can't come to the show
looking like Dragon Ball Z and Game of
Thrones together bro that [__] is crazy
if Goku is a taret Argan you can't sit
in the front row looking like that
that's one of the craziest haircuts I
ever seen do you guys even know this guy
and how do you know know since you were
teenagers oh wow and has his has his
haircuts
gotten yeah worse yeah roller coaster
it's a roller coaster yeah it looks like
it was cut while you were on a roller
coaster what is what is your job BR I
work in it you work in it oh yeah so
you're you can have
that I mean it it's [__] insane right
like I thought my [__] was unreasonable
but that is like it's so unreasonable I
haven't even talked about that guy's
shirt yet I've never seen a white dude
dressed like an African that just
arrived bro you got to stand up so
people can see the bro look at
this
bro is this the first day with her no oh
you're married oh wow
okay and this is a normal thing do you
put him in this
[__] you pick it out you're like nobody
going to [__] him in this [__] this is
just this is guaranteed
faithful baby go put on your faithful
shirt I need I need to feel comfy
tonight no [__] is trying to get some
dick from you it's your faithful shirt
bro that shirt look like it come with
like essential oil and [__] bro like
what the [__] is this shirt man bro
where did you get cuz it's it's supposed
to be a Coogi
sweater it's by Coogi but they didn't
knit it that's not by Coogi that's by
some Chinese children that's what that
[__] is by
bro are you white you are got like a big
watch and a pinky ring and [__] what's
going on with this guy over here he
either got the littlest or the biggest
dick there's that's this is not in
between Dick Energy Right Here a white
white dude to dress like that he got to
be packing something huge for a White
Guy like four or five Ines or something
like that like bro for you that's a
Tremor right that [__]
is he pulls out five Ines God
Zer straight to the a long time acting
like I was
a by
you
[Music]
is that your girlfriend right there and
then what's that guy right there that's
your best friend come on
bro come on bro this forever single ass
[__] out here man come
on say what you had her
first
Salt Lake is not supposed to be this
[__] crazy
man we got a goddamn thle in the front
[Applause]
row hold on you Behind the Music looking
[__] what
what the hell is happening over here so
wait a minute you guys are all friends
you guys hooked up first he was in
survival mode don't take that personally
like cuz I was about to go in and he was
like I got to stop this
somehow I [__] this girl
[Applause]
first
son n he had that [__] cocked ready to
go the second he found out he was in
front row he was third wheel he was like
now I'm telling everybody bro it is what
it is the whole Community is going to
know all right I'm not getting made fun
of and front all these people everybody
going to know we shared the
V oh that's
crazy yo you're a confident [__]
bro that's confidence dude I wouldn't
even let him sit next to her I'd sit in
the
middle the [__] is going
on here I was thinking you some [__]
virgin third wheel [__] you're
out here [__] down all your boys
girls this is
crazy this girl is getting so horny she
taking off her jacket
man
I don't even know what to say right
now hold on did you just find out this
information right now
sir so how long before you guys started
dating is this is this uncomfortable for
you sweetheart it's not yeah we
know we're
aware that's why we're having this
conversation not only have you been
through it they've been through it
don't flip your
[Applause]
hair you okay buddy you going to hold
yourself the whole show dog you're
making me feel uncomfortable I'm not
going to make fun of you man we're here
together what's your name Francisco nice
to meet
you that's your roommate that's what you
tell your parents bro
that's how long you guys been
roommates 5 years huh
y'all can't get gay married out here yet
or
what I don't think you guys are gay but
the more questions I ask I'm like n
they're definitely gay man is and that's
cool
Francisco I mean you're named after the
gayest place in America when you think
about
it man what do you do out here
bro for
Lululemon I knew I was on to something
bro do you wear BL lemons SMI not at all
it's not your thing what's your
thing Puerto Rico you wear Puerto
Rico just panties just that okay I'm
glad you answered that question cuz for
a moment I thought you were absolutely
[__]
[Applause]
uh it's nice being a hot girl right you
just say whatever and guy goes oh yeah
that makes s we some Puerto Rico good
love Puerto Rico why you not we Puerto
Rico you single you have a boyfriend are
you married you're single gotcha okay
how long you been single
for just a year okay are you enjoying
your time catching
bodies how many bodies you caught this
year you think
like a police
department what's the murder rate going
on around
there two the whole year two dicks the
whole year wow you ever worry that
you'll like lose your skill at sex if
you don't do it often you do you do
really woo yes control yourself
bro control
yourself this is a good this is a good
man right here cuz he heard that [__]
and he knew his wife was next to him he
didn't even look over it he just kept
eating his [__] hummus
dip just dipped another Chip he like
I'mma look straight I don't care about
all that ratchetness over there I'm a
happily married man I don't give a [__]
if [__] is eating dicks and [__]
at the same goddamn time where is she
where is she call the
[Applause]
boys dicks and [__] at the same time
that seems almost
impossible to eat a dick and a [__] at
the same time you would need two mouths
to do
that or a really small
penis where you could pack it on one
side like
tobacco
and then just lick [__] out the other
hand you must have a tongue like a
golden retriever
just oh God Francisco you've probably
eaten dicks and [__] what is it
like what do you do for a lemon I'm an
esthetician an esthetician so you just
be ripping out [__] hairs and [__] like
that that's a brave thing right there
you
self-employed
eyelashes you do eyelash
extensions eyebrow extensions now have
you combined both businesses so like you
tear out the [__] hairs and then put
in you never seen some [__] hairs that
were super straight like you get a nice
Filipino girl she got the straight [__]
hair [__] doesn't even curl it just goes
down
straight yep
you never seen that [__] he's got a part
that it looks like
bangs no this is serious so you've never
seen that no okay as a joke yes but in
real life all the [__] hair you see is
Curly have you ever seen a [__] and
then you've been like I can't work on
that thing right there that is that is
crazy that's absolutely horrifying never
once youve never you're not picky with
your
[__] because you're in there right
like they open up and it's hey how you
doing right you got the whole
encyclopedia you're just leafing through
that
thing so this is no I'm just saying it's
a very intimate thing I would never feel
comfortable going to
aesthetician it's too
intimate I mean obviously no disrespect
to you sir but like you're an attractive
woman I can't let you see my soft
pecker it's too intimate I don't even
let my doctor see my fo fully soft dick
I got a male doctor once he leaves the
room
I I just get a little blood down there
hit the head a few times then he comes
back and he's like oh yeah like yeah
that's right
[__] Okay you see that Medium
swole you see that Medium swole duck
check the testies and let's get out of
here I swear to God like two weeks ago
before I came here I remember thinking
like what the [__] am I going to talk
about I was so concerned I Google what
the [__] is going on in
Canada and there was a
headline
Punjabi that's what I'm talking about my
juts in the building baby let's
go all the way from the bramly city
center all the
[Applause]
way I saw the headline Punjabi he said
Punjabi
separatist
assassinated I said oh oh
no they got trud though they got him
they got him they got just thinder how
the
hell how the hell did they assassinate
just
sinder they forc him to kiss his wife on
camera how did
that then I look up the details of the
story the dude was assassinated India
sent some [__] here to
assassinate I'm like why is nobody
talking about this [__] story then I
looked up the guy who's assassinated
name his first name is
Hardeep his last name is spelled n
JJ
ER that's too close that's too [__]
close I'm sorry white people we can't
share this story we got to sit this one
out I saw punjabis in the streets like
say his name we're like like we would
love to but we can't we just can you
even give us that pass can you give us
an N word
pass and they shot him right that what
happened [__] Jesus now to be fair if
you're good assassinated any you got to
Sho cuz you can't po
them cuz y'all eat your food you
know Indian stomachs are indestructible
bro you could put plutonium and butter
chicken and they be like
a little spicy a little bit spicy
baby poisoning is for white people only
bro you could assassinate me with
cilantro bro I'm out easy they got shs
with a garnish bro they garnished
them all I'm saying T is unbelievable an
Indian was killed on Canadian
soil and it wasn't in a residential
school man can you
believe by the way the name of this
theater is the most Jewish name I've
ever
heard Meer Horowitz
theater is this next to the bagel drel
Arena
what bro that turban is Big
Dog hold on I got to see I've never seen
him hey put the spot on
bro you got a be considerate for the
people behind you for the show dude you
wore your tallest
turban damn bro do they got different
heights is today like a really religious
day that you got
the are you like the king
Punjab so that's a high one is that not
a high one cuz you never cut your hair
huh so you got to wrap all that [__] in
there dog you know what you could do you
could cut it no one would [__]
know
why do some of them have a knot but
yours
doesn't like some of them have a
knot yeah the KN is up there but yours
looks like you could put like apples and
pears and [__] on the
[Applause]
top sorry what there's layers to it so
wait are you like a better version of
Indian wait you earn that you earn the
bowl and then how do you earn that one
what do you got to do you turned
12 holy [__] dude it's like the opposite
of Jews like you get a little bit more
on your
[Applause]
[Music]
head I didn't know y'all had a bar
mitzvah what's it called when you turned
12 dude Mitzvah thank you sweetheart I'm
talking talking to the brown
guy are you the representative for Meer
Horowitz here is
[Music]
it what is it bro what is it
called the the star
of thank you
dog I can't imagine how big your [__] is
cuz you know
it
this [__] walking around like
the pope of India
dog I don't even know if you're Indian I
assume you're Indian what type of Indian
I am Punjabi Punjabi are you sick yeah
I'm sick [__] with sick man those are
the dudes that wear the turban and [__]
and they got that bracelet that little
silver bracelet that's a badass
bracelet no for real cuz back in the day
that used to be a sheath that would
protect them from swords cuz is the six
with a warrior class of people in India
and then over the years you know the
meaning has changed now it's used to
rest on a steering wheel of a uber
but
son if they got that bracelet locked on
that steering wheel though they never
crashing dude never crashing